[Music]
[Applause]
okay all right
so yeah I'm soccerberry this talk is
about kerning and video sin or
synthesizer with JavaScript and of
course the browser a little bit about me
at thanks for the introduction
yeah work at UCF and obviously I love
javascript in the browser which is why
I'm here
yeah it's the minimum proposal on the
last day kind of like a what the heck
why not really didn't think I'd be
picked and yet here I am so that's why
this was the official photo that I gave
the conference this was my family I was
visiting back home in Panama City Beach
and my parents were like hey come down
to the beach and this was the result and
her promises wasn't intentional but that
is indeed a J has come 15 shirt yeah so
I'm super thrilled to be able to visit
the conference in Amelia Island and now
to be able to present so that's super
cool and a promise it was not
intentional okay so the inspiration for
this idea we're gonna start off with a
little experiment this is some code that
I'm gonna try to run through real quick
and I'll show you what it does it's
going to take the whole body element and
it's going to shove it into Marky which
I know if you knew this but Marky does
have options so you can speed it up and
reverse it we're also going to select
all the spans and H ones and so so have
you and then on each of those want to
put those in a marquee
because we can and then we're gonna make
an angle variable and then send an
interval and then we're just gonna
increment that for every dip on the page
and we're gonna do that every
millisecond so let's see we have Jes
comp let's run this and see what happens
so it'll come back around
yeah and it's a little bit fast but you
can still use it if I was able to click
on a button it would still work I tried
it I'm not gonna try here cuz it's hard
but enough of that so what was the point
of that right so browser is a powerful
rendering engine I'm kind of surprising
and put uh Martina Marquis in a monkey
and you can rotate the whole page in it
for the most part handles it and the
marquee tag still works backwards
compatibility is awesome
so that's that's I'm kind of trying to
lay out like kind of the concept of the
idea that's one little piece of my brain
the other piece is something that I've
been kind of excited about which is
modular synthesis I'm kind of excited -
yesterday on the Erb not yesterday but
the first day I talked someone did have
a photo of like a modular set up which
was really cool but I will let Andrew
Huang a famous youtuber explain because
he can explain it better than I can so
let's see if this works
maybe let's see if I can turn this up
okay well no but I'll try to explain it
then so each of these pieces is a little
module and you can plug them together so
some of them create audio so it's just
like a simple sine or square waveform
others can then manipulate and manage
that audio and and transform it in
different ways so thank you this
crowd-sourced okay so output should be
headphones okay all right thank you all
right all right so how this relates to
JavaScript so module sentence this is
composed of several modules and those
take input and give output that's kind
of it's a little bit of a stretch but
that's kind of like how functional
programs are made you kind of combine
and composed several functions they take
input and give output third piece of my
brain is I started producing music
electronic music and I needed something
to put into the SoundCloud little
thumbnail thing for album art so I
generated I wrote this application that
generates SVG's dynamically and so if I
clicked on one of these it would
download a two thousand four two
thousand PNG and I can reload just to
show you it's it's live so that was
really cool I was pretty happy with that
but the code is terrible and when I I
would have to go through and edit the
code and like make changes so like maybe
I didn't like this one color I wanted
there to be more circles and more lines
and that was kind of a tedious process
and I thought it would be really cool if
I could tweak these parameters live
with some sort of user interface and
then I showed you modular synthesis we
subtract to explain it audio is another
signal and so is video so you can do the
same type of thing with video as well so
this is the this is a video modular
synth and it can like take the red
channel then you can manipulate that and
transform video in different ways
hopefully this works but this is a
friend of mine who has a huge video
modular set up this is a little demo of
him kind of tweaking some parameters
live so he's changing the effect of the
video here and so it's actually not that
new
the first visualizer as far as I
understand it was back in 1977 with the
Atari video music and that is the same
Atari they're thinking of for like the
2600 and to my knowledge the first time
it was used was in the background of a
Devo video so I figured I'd show it to
you
so basically the Atari video music works
by it takes audio signals and then it
kind of it's it's a little black box but
it it makes these diamond patterns and
weird squiggly and this was a good
example because some of the stuff can be
super flashy I didn't want to show that
but there are a few parameters you can
tweak to them modify how that works so
all this stuff is really cool I love a
lot and it's very kind of this VHS low
fine 90s 80s kind of thing but I also
like very digital type of aesthetics so
here's two examples of some of that
hopefully
that's one and then here's the other so
as you can see that's kind of reacting
to the audio it's very purposely built
to do that but that got me thinking it'd
be really cool to be able to create
these videos live as I was performing
music and they're simple to the point
that at least graphically wise they're
simple so that I could totally make
these with like a canvas or SVG
application and then going with that
it's crazy how much again with the power
of the browser we have CSS animations 2d
3d graphics you have SVG we have video
we have awesome libraries like 3GS pics
ejs and this is obviously just - and a
huge multitude of libraries and we have
all these api's and some of the talks
that you've seen here talk about some of
these cool api's so why don't we harness
this technology and so that's the idea
so let's see oh right this is this is
not my app yet this is another site okay
so and then the idea here is that we
have all this types of hardware and all
this Hardware sends different signals so
here I have a ps4 a gamepad you can see
that and the mouse audio this is like
reading the audio level from the MacBook
and then those are many messages so
would it be cool if we could then
harness all of those kind of as a signal
kind of like drawing inspiration from
the video modular synth and each of
these can be harnessed through different
api's so gamepad is gamepad API
obviously media capture and streams here
is just for audio but you can also do
video which I'll show you in a little
bit
and then those can send signals over to
some sort of application that
application can harness those libraries
and those web api s but what we could
also do is that we could at least the
idea is to remap those live so we could
change the configuration and then change
the visualization as a result
so let's get into that so this is
probably built it's an application
called bit kid let me see if I can make
it bigger the idea is that we have kind
of a software version of a visual sense
so here we have the mouse node that's
reading the Dom events from the mouse
and then as I move back and forth it's
changing these x and y-values and those
are being put into the inner to the
display up there which i am calling the
screen so if I full screen here you can
see it's simple it's just showing you
the the pixel values but what I can do
is an example is let's see look actually
there's a good example so all of those
nodes are just JavaScript and they're
kind of inspired by web components they
actually are web components but these
are own life cycle methods so anything
that you see in the node can be changed
up here is the inputs so those can be
defined with like what kind of a value
they accept as well as other options so
let me put these together and what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna hook up the
x-value of the mouse to rotate our
screen so with that little change I'm
able to now the mouse is kind of
controlling the rotate the CSS rotation
of this element here so just a quick
overview of how it works this is what I
said this is the screen element these
are what I call nodes each node has
optionally a list of inputs and listed
outputs there's also the web component
that I spoke about and then each of the
inputs optionally has a UI that kind of
lets you set the values if you don't set
them through some sort of hardware
method and then those can be connected
and how it works is each of those like I
showed you that code that's the node J
is not I don't mean the framework node
but I mean like the JavaScript that
makes up each node and then those gate
eval into
basically a web component class and then
I have a CSS and HTML which then gets
put into a shadow root and then that
those combined into my custom web
component that I built for this and then
we have a react layer which then that
was what the graphical interface of
connecting all of the nodes but also
each react component has a native web
component in it which is kind of a
nightmare
and then we have the state which this is
very simple but a simplified view but
it's basically what note is connected to
what node and what are the values that
every any given point in time and then
we have the screen element at the upper
right and that's just a web page has
HTML and CSS and that gets shoved into
an iframe so I wanted to talk a little
bit about some of the technology behind
it web components I'm sure a lot of you
have seen it but in case you haven't you
can make any sort of classics and HTML
element or other HTML elements if you'd
like like the paragraph tag and you get
these life cycle events so you get
connected callback that's when it gets
attached to the Dom disconnected I want
to get removed when it gets removed from
the Dom adopted means has moved to
another document but the one that I'm
really harnessing here is observed
tributes so what you can do is you can
define different attributes on the HTML
element and then you get a callback that
gets fired whenever those attributes
change and there's real quickly how you
would use it you might make like for
example a user icon web element you
define it using custom elements defined
I should say this only works I believe
in Chrome and I think it's coming to
Firefox soon there's some polyfills but
you say I whenever I see a user - icon
tag I want you to use that user icon
class and then you can make your custom
element all the code examples I'm going
to be showing you can get to with this
bitly URL I just have a code pen
collection of a bunch of kind of the
basics of what I'm showing you if you're
curious
so writing to the iframe is actually
surprisingly easy and one of the
examples I have code pen ink
pen because all you need to do is you
can get the the an iframe element you
can open it document I'll open you can
shove a bunch of HTML in there you can
then create a new style element and then
you can just put that into the head of
the iframe that you just created so it's
kind of hacky but what's great about
this is now you stand box it so if you
tend to if you write some weird HTML I
don't have to worry about it throwing
errors the iframe was just coner sort of
deal with it
so I heard somebody laugh with eval this
is a famous kind of thing from Douglas
Crockford where he said evil is evil and
basically you should never use it but I
wanted to make kind of a little
amendment except one it's using a weird
art project then you're good at least
you have my permission you can blame me
in fact it's a little punk rock because
it's kind of impressive that you can do
this with the language so here's how to
be evil eval
maybe you've avoided it for so long you
actually don't know how it works
you can give it a string of text and
then that will be parsed as JavaScript
runtime and then you'll get back if it
for example here I'm returning or
setting the value of x I can then get
that value back out and then how to be a
little bit less evil is you can use a
new function which is actually what I am
using but what's really cool is you can
pass attributes as strings to function
and then the last attribute can be code
and then when you actually keep that
function here returns the expect the
result that adds these numbers so I'm
not saying that you should probably go
out with your like Equifax J s like
server-side application and start
emailing everything because it's
incredibly inefficient but for what I
needed to do it was perfect okay so the
real point of what I was trying to do is
I was trying to combine CSS transitions
and drum machines so I will show that
here I have a webcam over like a switch
there's my face
on seconds this was kind of a way to
talk because just jammed all the
technology I could find into a talk and
hoped it would go well refresh this page
okay unfortunately no well trust me that
I have have a drum machine up here it's
the roland tr-808 the
these circles will just change their
setting to a random size and position
and to get back to what i was talking
about with the screen this is that
screen this is just fine H you know this
is what I shove into the eye frame and
then the the thing that makes it work is
just this transition here it's just 200
millisecond animation so I could change
that if I wanted to but but it's not
just about clicking the button it's
about connecting the hardware so what I
can do is I have a note here that takes
the MIDI messages from here and splits
it out into different channels so I know
you can't see this but it slipped
between bass drum snare drum and all the
different sounds so what I will do is I
will hook up the bass drum to this guy
and each of these nodes I'm connecting
it to those are just I'll show you those
just oh wait sorry that's just to show
you those all connect to this circle guy
and the circle simply just sets the
attribute of the ID or the element
that's the XY and the scale of them
oh sorry
connecting everything all right
so you show you whatever reason the pink
one doesn't want to cooperate but so
want to hit these buttons it's just
changing that all over maps so that's
the idea
thank you
[Applause]
okay so this is just another example
this is just a static set of SPG's but
they have two different states so when
they listen to this and then I can add
yeah thank you and again if I especially
that it literally it's just SPG's baked
and straight from illustrator I didn't
indent it you know who cares it's an art
project that's fine okay so many there
were some talks already about many the
on the first day there was talks about
Bimini which is a supercool project it's
kind of confusing because there's MIDI
as many files those are kind of like
plays sound what I'm talking about here
is MIDI signals so pretend that you are
an electronic music composer and it's
1981 and you have a keyboard a sin and
it plays all some sounds and it's really
cool but then you like okay I need to
enhance my sound so I want some drums to
go with this you get a 1981 drum machine
and it sounds awesome then you get
something else because you're addicted
and you buy too much stuff the problem
is that they all speak their own
language so when you want them to talk
together they can't and then in 1982 the
MIDI standard comes about to solve this
problem and now everything can play
together I realized I think I have flux
on that's why things look orange okay
okay so how that works is you have your
keyboard right and you play a note and
it makes a sound but if it's MIDI
enabled that also sends out a message so
it's going to say hey you've played
middle C and then you play a lower note
and hey you've played F and I don't want
to go super in-depth into it but the
message is it's just data
it describes like you press note on
that's the type Channel there can be 16
channels how hard you pressed it and
that's just binary and there's tons of
different messages I don't want to cover
them all but like knobs and clock and
tempo and that thing that's all there
but what's great is that you can connect
to that see web MIDI and what that looks
like is you request many acts
then you get the mini access and then
for each of the inputs you can just
listen for a mini message and then you
get back event that data is just a
special array that has the three bytes
that I showed you on the previous slide
and that's it it's super low level it's
great oh I forgot I forgot to show you
the gamepad demo actually maybe you do
that okay okay and so here I have the
gamepad mapped I saw it for a second
there we go okay so I have this gamepad
here this is just a PlayStation 4
controller and I have the axis here to
find to then set the background probably
isn't important to show you that but I
did I remember this part all right yeah
so how that works is you can just listen
for gamepad connected you can get the
index because there's basically I think
at least on Chrome there's kind of four
slots of those game pads go go into and
then you can requestanimationframe you
basically are gonna pull for the values
that's that so here you can get the game
as you do that each time and then you
can log out the values of that the axes
or the buttons just a number from
negative one to one and then you just
keep pulling it so it's super easy
next is video in canvas I've never had
that happen before
let me try connecting this to another
USB port and maybe that was
that seems promising sweet okay all
right so I'll show you this what this is
is this is just reading my webcam but
there's a layer on top that is you say
it's putting it to canvas and then on
canvas it's reading the pixel values and
then just summing up the color of that
pixel just because why not it looks cool
so hello Jay has come can't make you
guys out so yeah that's what this looks
like to show you the code behind that to
grab the webcam is also pretty easy
you ask for user media you ask for video
you get a stream back you can dump that
into a video element and just tell it to
play and it works and then of course
error callback which you saw right demo
canvas is easy as well I'm sure canvas
has been out for a while so you've
probably messed with it but just in case
you have it you can make a canvas
element you can get to make a video
element you get the context is how you
work with canvas and then you can draw
on to the context which draws with the
canvas an image and that first attribute
is our video tag so that's what I'm
dumping the webcam into and I'm just
reading it back off of that and then I
can do whatever I want so here's just an
example of how to grab the color of a
single pixel and here's another video
example and this one should work with me
so let's try it
okay so what this does is when it hits a
kick drum it's gonna splash the screen
but when it gets that chord sound it's
gonna randomly rotate with a rotate why
a CSS transition the whole thing and on
top of that is my pixel canvas and I'm
kind of changing the height based on
perspective where that is and hopefully
thank you so thanks for being here in
the first year scoff music video all
right so what are the problems with this
approach I don't want to get too into it
because it's nasty and annoying but
putting a web component in a reactor is
a terrible idea the virtual DOM and the
way we act works I think it somehow
triggers those connected and
disconnected callbacks all the time
so I just can't use them I try to get
around it for a couple of days and I run
out of time is like okay I'm just not
going to use it so instead you yeah
sorry then you just don't use them
another problem is that the nodes are
all evil if you edit a node and then
save it that causes a problem because
the custom elements already defined and
I can't redefine it so you can just
depend the date to the name of the tag
that you create and you're good
get attribute in the cut and the element
always return strings that's just kind
of how get attribute works so I don't
use it I get around it so I have my own
get attribute function and then I have
the native one that I've overridden that
you can still get to you also can't at
least I couldn't catch the errors so
when when you wrote like some JavaScript
in the app and then it ran and then you
got a value it would throw an error at
the whole thing we kind of just died so
I needed to basically wrap actually
change call back and so I have my own
attribute change call back as well
performance get a faster computer
actually no I did do a little bit of
work with this so react has should
component update which lets you try to
optimize the truth is I didn't get that
far into it and there's only so many
requests animation frames you can run
before your browser crawls
but that's future would so yeah there's
a lot of problems
whatever prior art if you've if you've
done any sort of visualization stuff
this probably looks somewhat familiar
turns out there's a lot of things that
do this when I started out I was
thinking oh man this is really cool
I've never seen like a visual like
modular software and know there's lots
of examples but these are really cool so
she I just recently learned about touch
designer looks super awesome so I
recommend you check it out if you're
interested into this last example is
they have a very cheesy synth wave song
with a demo so hopefully this works
so that basically just treating this
grid thing as input and output I have
these walls here so it's a little bit
hard to see but up in the corner I can
trigger the walls I can trigger the
background so all the examples have
shown hardware talking to JavaScript no
I don't use but you can use a loopback
meeting device for the software to talk
to itself so this is a logic file which
I will play so the walls are done on
every drum head and the background is
also pulsing with the drum head and I'll
use a hue rotate CSS transform in a
second on the MIDI notes that come in to
change the color and then after that
there'll be one more thing
that's that's this part on the column
again that's all the code examples the
app is a big kid app it's on a super
cheap digital ocean box so I might crash
the code is public it's a big kid I'd
love to get pull requests it was made on
a deadline for this so it's a little bit
rough
I don't really is Twitter that much
anymore so if you want to follow me on
instagram i'm at zap underscore danger
and that's all i have the only thing i
didn't show you was the audio so you can
also read the microphone and put it in
there
so that's all I got
[Applause]